Welcome to Intro to Psychology.
I'm Lauren.
I'm Susan.
And I'm Greg.
We're your instructors for this course.
We're going to take you
on your journey through psychology.
We'll go over different areas of psychology
and how different psychologists examine
and explain thought and behavior.
We are all very different.
We like different things.
We think differently.
We even react differently.
So for instance, I have something here
that might create
different reactions in people.
Ooh. Look at this guy.
My snake Tickles. I've come to really
enjoy him. He's a nice snake.
I wouldn't mind holding Tickles
or touching him but I certainly
wouldn't want him as a pet.
Lauren?
No, no, I don't do snakes.
You don't do snakes.
No. I don't do snakes.
The perfect example of how people
react differently to different situations.
So, there's many different areas
of psychology, for instance,
personality psychologists would look
at what's going on here
and try to really understand
the individual differences in the fear
and why I'm not really afraid, you're
fine and she's more or less terrified.
behavioral Psychologists might look
at an individual's learning history.
So, for example I was exposed to a lot
of snakes when I was growing up.
So, perhaps I've learned that snakes
aren't dangerous for me.
And a Social Psychologist may look
at how other people's behavior
influences our own. So, for example,
looking at other people's reactions
may influence our own reactions.
A biological psychologist, perhaps,
may look at Lauren's fright response
in terms of increase in heart rate,
or even sweating. And a neuroscientist.
They may look at the areas of the brain
that are activated during the fear response,
such as the amygdala.
But for now, I think it's time
for Tickles to head home.
Even though this example exploited
my fear of snakes. Thanks a lot Greg.
It was a really effective tool for Susan
and Greg to use to show you just
how diverse psychology can be.
Now psychology is defined as a study
of thought and behavior
and is an amazing way
to make sense of our world